moi je sais que j'ai ma conscience
je sais que je n'ai jamais rien fait qui
soit hors de la morale de l'acceptable
avant damien abad d'autres ministres ont
été accusés de viols durant le précédent
quinquennat et à chaque fois emmanuel
macron ne les a pas lâchés
début 2018 le ministre de la transition
écologique nicolas hulot voir ressortir
dans le journal l'hebdo une affaire de
violences sexuelles concernant 2008 une
femme l'avait accusé de viol pour des
faits remontant à 1997 donc prescrits la
plainte a été classée sans suite mais
dix ans plus tard quand nicolas hulot
voit réapparaître cette affaire il prend
les devants et s'exprime dans les médias
avant même la parution d'articles et
comme je sais que ce journal va
puisqu'ils blondy fait référence à ces
deux affaires qui n'en sont pas
j'ai pas de budget personne n'a déposé
plainte contre moi il n'y a pas une
jeune femme qui a une parole et moi une
parole différente le bail à un moment il
faut il y en a marre dans cette affaire
le gouvernement soutient nicolas hulot
secrétaire d'état en charge de l'égalité
femmes hommes marlène schiappa publie
une tribune dans la presse pour défendre
son collègue et dénoncer les pratiques
du journal l'hebdo qui mélange rumeurs
et plein de classer sans suite des
méthodes qui selon elles causent du tort
au mouvement mitu de libération de la
parole des femmes cette tribune de
marianne chapa elle a fait beaucoup
réagir cette tribune est malheureuse
c'est à dire qu' elle n'est pas la
tribune qu'on attende la secrétaire
d'état chargée de l'égalité femmes
hommes parce que d'abord cette tribune
part du principe comme tous les propos
d'ailleurs de tous les membres du
gouvernement que dans cette affaire il y
aurait
spontanément une confiance accordée à un
des deux protagonistes
nicolas hulot quelques mois plus tard
nicolas hulot quitte le gouvernement
mais seulement pour des désaccords
politiques avec emmanuel macron en
revanche en 2021 quand d'autres femmes
l'accusent de viols et d'agressions
sexuelles l'écologiste décide de se
retirer définitivement de la vie
publique suite à ces accusations la
justice a ouvert une enquête l'autre
membre du gouvernement accusé de
violences sexuelles durant le précédent
quinquennat c'est gérald darmanin à
l'été 2010 est une femme porte plainte
contre lui pour des faits remontant à
2009 selon elle gérald darmanin lui
aurait demandé des faveurs sexuelles en
échange d'une aide dans un dossier
judiciaire février 2010 une autre femme
accuse gérald darmanin de lui avoir
promis un soutien dans une demande de
logement en échange d'une relation
sexuelle très vite les plaintes sont
classées sans suite mais en juin 2020 la
cour d'appel de paris relance les
investigations judiciaires visant gérald
darmanin et le gouvernement vient en
soutien du ministre on ne peut pas d'un
côté sacraliser la présomption
d'innocence en toutes circonstances et
considérer que c'est un socle essentiel
de notre pays ce qui est notre cas je
crois je l'espère à tous et considérer
qu'il y aurait des personnes qui par la
fonction qu'elle occupe ne pourraient
pas bénéficier cette présomption
d'innocence juillet 2020 gérald darmanin
est promu ministre de l'intérieur pour
les associations féministes et pour
l'opposition de gauche c'est une
provocation mais le nouveau chef du
gouvernement jean castex assume cette
nomination avec le président vous
affichez votre soutien sans faille au
ministre de l'intérieur sans même
attendre la fin de la procédure
judiciaire
c'est une erreur éthique politique d'une
violence symbolique inouïe monsieur
darmanin n'a fait l'objet d'aucune
condamnation et à ce que je sache à
chaque fois que l'autorité judiciaire a
eu à se prononcer dans cette affaire
elle a rendu des actes consacre à
l'innocence de monsieur darmanin
aujourd'hui gérald darmanin ne fait plus
l'objet d'une enquête judiciaire dans
cette affaire et il a d'ailleurs été
reconduits ministre de l'intérieur dans
le gouvernement d habib bande
[Musique]